heart attacks during pregnancy are
increasing among women in the u.s. a
12-year study led by NYU School of
Medicine is out this morning it found
the risk of having a heart attack while
pregnant giving birth or during the two
months after delivery rose 25% from 2002
to 2014 four and a half percent of the
women who had heart attacks died dr.
Holly Anderson is a cardiologist at New
York Presbyterian while Cornell Medical
Center good morning great joining you on
so why are we seeing an increased number
of pregnant women having heart attacks
while they're pregnant and then
postpartum I'm not surprised at all
because when you look at the national
data heart disease deaths and young
women have been increasing since the
year 2000 so it makes sense that that
heart attacks are happening more in our
pregnant women as well what do you mean
by young women what's Adria talking
about we look at young women to be 29 to
45 this study looked at women 18 and
above who are pregnant between the year
2002 and 2014 25% increase is
significant so what do you attribute it
to well first of all pregnancy is a big
risk on the heart so when when a
pregnant women is significantly more
likely to have a heart attack than non
pregnant women because you have a bigger
blood volume you gain weight your heart
increases your heart rate increases your
blood pressure increases and right at
the time of delivery you have to prevent
bleeding so your body clamps down and
you become more likely to form blood
clots all predispose you to heart
attacks but I think what's happening in
our young women is that the risk factors
for heart disease are increasing in this
country high blood pressure high
cholesterol diabetes are all higher in
our younger women and I think stress
probably plays a factor as well so what
could women do who are pregnant please
I'd like all women to know that heart
disease is the number one cause of death
for women and it's increasing in young
women and it's a very preventable
disease
so know your risk factors and work to
decrease them blood pressure your weight
your sugar levels don't smoke get your
get your your sugar levels checked and
your cholesterol levels checked and your
blood pressure checked and work to get
it better you know eat right exercise
try to good good night's sleep
but talk to your doctor about your risk
factors it's really important to bring
this up when you're seeing your doctor
to emphasize it's a preventable
preventible very much doctor thanks so
much dr. Anderson